to start the event many afghans have
been waiting for for decades
face-to-face peace talks between the
government and the taliban
united states secretary of state mike
pompeo flew to the opening ceremony in
doha qatar
and urged the warring sides to seize the
opportunity
look the choice of your political system
is of course yours to make
in the united states we found that
democracy notably the principle of
peaceful resolution
and rotation of political power works
best
democratic systems reflect the choices
of the majority while protecting
the human rights of everyone everyone
that includes women and minorities
their rights have been largely neglected
by the taliban
it's just one of the several points the
two sides disagree on
the use of violence is another the chair
of the high council for national
reconciliation
called for an immediate humanitarian
ceasefire
we have come here with good will and
good intention to stop the fourth years
of bloodshed
and achieve a countrywide and lasting
peace
but the taliban have long worried that
reducing violence could give them less
leverage at the negotiation table
in their opening statement they instead
focused on their desire to include
tenants of islam
and any future afghan government in this
ceremony i request and i hope that
both sides pay attention to the
provisions of holy relation of
islam the warring sites offer two
dramatically different versions of a
post-war afghanistan
but the leaders meeting today stressed
that violence is no path
towards a harmonious afghanistan
well for more on these historical peace
talks let's cross now to journalist ali
latifi in kabul ali thanks for joining
us
what are negotiators on both sides
hoping to achieve and where do you think
we might see the biggest sticking points
the biggest sticking points will
obviously be around a ceasefire
because you know the the taliban are
hesitant to declare
a nationwide long-term ceasefire they
have declared two ceasefires
in the past year or so previously the
government also initiated a ceasefire
but this will be a major major sticking
point and then for the government
a major issue for them is sort of
retaining this idea of the republic
and making sure that their seats are
secure
um because you know there are a lot of
people
uh within the government that the
taliban and other groups and even people
within afghanistan
you know might find suspect we're
talking about former communists about
warlords about
uh people who as young people put it
parachuted in
uh from foreign countries and don't
necessarily understand the
cultural and religious and aspects of
the country or the languages
uh so these types of people are very
afraid for their jobs
so maintaining the republic is also very
important for them
so these are the kinds of things that
will really that could really sort of
hold up the talks
right now the taliban has said it wants
an islamic government
that is also inclusive one of the
interesting things that's going to come
out of these talks is that the taliban
is going to have to clearly lay out
their political vision for the country
what are we expecting to hear
well this is the thing is what we hear
is up to them
because this has been the question that
has been asked of them of their
supporters
of other groups within the government or
within avalon society
who have sort of similar views is that
what does it mean that you want an
islamic society because
all aspects of avalon society are based
on islam whether you're talking about
the laws or the constitution
or the education system everything has
to fall within
the parameters of sharia and islam and
islamic jurisprudence
and all of these things so the
government the taliban finally has to be
up front and say when we mean
an islamic system this is what we mean
because you know for instance they're in
doha
in doha women work they drive they they
go out to shopping centers you know they
have shisha they go to cafes whatever
so if they're trying to sort of
implement what they did in 1996
it'll kind of fall flat because they'll
be like you're just in this country for
all these years where
women had these sorts of rights all
right and now
after almost two decades in afghanistan
the u.s has agreed to a timeline for
withdrawing foreign troops in a february
deal with the taliban
are these negotiations expected to
produce the kind of results that the us
and its nato allies are hoping for
that's exactly what the u.s wants and
you know the way when it was announced
that mike pompeo would be coming
that he replying from washington for
these talks
that's how people envisioned his role is
that he would be
the enforcer right almost like the
principal in a school full of unruly
children
ensuring that they come to an agreement
and ensuring that they
lay out the steps on both sides
necessary for the us to withdraw
and for donald trump to be able to
declare that he was finally
the us president to end the 20-year
involvement in afghanistan
so this is very very important for the
united states as well
all right journalist ali latifi thank
you
thank you